let's go to our caller from the 7/7 for  area code 774 is risky it's often a  local caller and it's sometimes it goes  well sometimes it goes not so well  what's what's going on now I can barely  hear you my friend is there so I might  actually need you to speak up a little  bit  David I'm here buddy but I'm telling you  that's blood on the streets and I'm  trying to be careful I'm not trying to  be throughout okay David yes okay listen  Dave I am a socialist I like social I  like socializing or is this pet producer  a friend again from a different  numbering are we not turning into  anti-social okay that's the whole thing  oh you hung up okay I think that's Pat's  friend who just likes to make puns on  the term socialism it's really odd